if i told you that i am about to
tell you the ultimate way to learn
a language would you believe me how many times have you
heard someone on the internet say
that they are ready to show you the ultimate and best
way to learn english
french or another language hello i am luca
lampariello i am a  language coach
who speaks 14 languages ​​including spanish
on this channel helps people
learn foreign languages
more efficiently fast and fun
the problem with using the magic word
better when it comes to methods
strategies and resources is that better is
subjective what  what's best for you
may not be best for me but
when people are looking for advice on how to
do something right that's the first thing they
ask for they want the best the fastest
and usually the cheapest
this ranges from learning to play the
guitar to learn how to make money and
pick up girls and yes of course
even learn a foreign language
people are obsessed with the best
so that's what they're looking for if that's
what you're looking for
then I have bad news for you
after 30 years learning languages ​​and
10 years recruiting people to
do the same I'm 100% sure
when I tell them the following no  there is
a better and faster way to learn
a language but I hope before you go
watch another video you should know that there
is also good news if it is true there
is no better and faster way to
learn a language but definitely
there is a better and faster way  quick
for you personally to learn a
language a method that suits your
likes and dislikes your
learning style and your schedule
all you need to do is find out
what this method is however you don't
need to do it just today you and
me  together we will discover a method
built on solid
learning principles personalized for you and your
circumstances and applicable to any
language you ultimately want to learn
the method  What you use
should have seven key characteristics
should be unique to your circumstances
should be enjoyable in a way that
suits your interests should be flexible
for different learning scenarios and environments
should allow you to learn
every day should be built
around learning resources
claros should incorporate the four
main language skills which
are reading, writing and listening comprehension and
speaking and should grow and
evolve according to your own
experiences and desires let's look at each of
these in more detail
have you ever wondered why
most people  fail to
learn a language at school there are
many reasons but one of the most
obvious is that schools employ a one
size fits all instruction method
regardless of your
personal interests and learning styles and
goals each student is forced to
listen to the same lectures they use  the
same textbook has  do the same
homework and receive the same types of
assessments now i know the
school environment is not the best for implementing
truly personalized learning
but the truth remains the same
everyone and we all learn
differently how you do a
task will have a  big impact on whether
or not you as an individual learn the
desired skill or memorize the
desired information and that how it
should align with your personality taste
and drive as a human being
let's go back to those language classes just
for a moment let's assume you're
learning English and that  your
english teacher loves history as a
result the entire curriculum of the
course is in one way or another tied to
historical events be it the
french revolution world war 2
or the civil war in spain
now let's also say you love history
english but you personally hate
history couldn't care less
given your dislike of history  which is
that you will learn in your English class
just like your classmate who
loves to read and talk about Napoleon
and his friends I tell you that is not going to
happen you learn better from things that
you find interesting if you are a big
fan of  sports would be much
much better in your hypothetical
French class if you read a lot of interviews of
French footballers I firmly believe
that we have to learn the language
through the themes and activities that do not
move
that excites us if you combine your
language learning with those
activities you will have  An
unbeatable combination that will always motivate you. For
example, I remember that when I started
learning Spanish I loved reading
interesting articles in
the country's Sunday newspaper. Besides
enjoying what we learn, we also
have to enjoy how we learn
if it is an online method like the  best
way to learn a language may sound
great but what if it requires you to
learn in one hand  it was that you don't like it or
it bores you supremely you should
continue with that online method not for
your health and sanity don't force yourself to use
a method you hate no matter how
good other people tell you it is will only
lead to disappointment and
ultimately  to burnout that's what i
've seen as a language coach i've
spent years and years developing my
two-way translation method a
learning strategy i've
found to work
brilliantly for me and most of
the students
i work with however  if a
student tries the method and they don't
like it don't push them instead we go
ahead and try a different method
in general people will follow the
learning strategy they
like best not the one everyone says is the
best
so find the method that suits them best  you like it
and follow it on fire
when i first develop my
two-way translation method i
apply it to each and every
idi  omas who said learn most
of the time it worked
great i would say i had amazing success
using the method in 10 languages
including spanish however when i tried to
use the method with japanese something
completely different happened it didn't work
hit a wall and couldn't
move forward  stubborn i decided to go
ahead anyway but no matter how hard i
tried to apply and reapply my
tried and tested two way translation method i couldn't get
anywhere in hindsight what i
should have done then was be
flexible i should have got my
translation method  bidirectional and trying to
adapt it to better suit
Japanese instead of the other way
around instead i remained rigid and inflexible
in my learning strategies and
that's why i failed. below i'll show you
how you can be flexible in
your learning even in those
moments when  who hits a
wall once a month stop and participate
in an exercise of self-reflection
ask yourself what I'm doing is
nice it's working well for me I
wake up every day wanting to
learn if not how can I
combine things so that all the
answers to the previous questions
yes answer these questions you
it allows you to readjust and re-evaluate your
learning methods making them
stronger and more adaptable in the long term do
all of this in writing take a piece of
paper a pencil or a pen and write down
your thoughts
that is something i tell you in every video
interview and article on my blog
ad nauseam if you want to learn
effectively make sure you learn every
day if you can do that time will
become your best ally to
progress in your language learning
because if you can learn
every day even for just five
minutes it will help you  the so-called
compound effect the gains you make
every day will add up slowly but
surely  like a snowball
rolling down the side of a mountain very
soon what was once a small
snowball will turn into something
much much much bigger when this
concept is applied to
language learning you will see results that exceed
even your expectations more  I will never
forget when a friend of mine called me
with some amazing news. He had been
learning Japanese for a long time
without much success, but one day he decided to
take my advice and commit to
learning for at least an hour
every day
the news after only six months.
even having an
hour-long conversation with native speakers something that
had previously only been a dream to you
keep this fundamental idea in mind at
all times language learning
is not something you do for just a
few weeks or months instead it is a
skill  for a lifetime learning
every day will help make that
happen
if you've ever tried to learn a
language  then you probably know
the feeling of learning for a few
months and then you try to watch a movie
in the language you're learning to
see how effectively you're learning you
turn on netflix and start seeing slam
dunk stuff that will bump or even with
subtitles of any kind
i'm sure  that you found you
understood a lot less than you
expected too i'm sure you
found it overwhelming and perhaps a bit
daunting first things first
let me tell you it's extremely
normal to feel this way
authentic content at a native level is
extremely difficult and to understand
your brain  you need massive amounts
of information for a long long
time so how do you get there
especially from where you find it
now how do you go from understanding nothing
to understanding almost everything here is the
answer you must consume a large
amount of information understandable in
simple terms
things you can understand  to  as you
learn new words and phrases you must
digest the content of those words and
phrases as well as some things you have never
seen before what you already know will
serve as context for the
new and unfamiliar items and gradually you will
also discover what
the new things mean
this  is the cycle of
understandable information learn from what you can
understand mostly until you
can understand it all and then move on
to the next resource mostly
you can understand to get started I
personally recommend anything
with print and audio and even
audiovisual materials with subtitles
other beneficial features
include
simple and clear explanations and grammar notes
vocabulary lists or even
complete translations into your native language this type
of material facilitates your quick
understanding of the content and as a
consequence makes it more pleasant
and fun to learn with it and with
enough comprehensible information  responsive in
the early stages
it won't be long before you can
venture into content designed
specifically for
native speakers to enjoy
and many language learning methods
focus on a single skill,
for example you can easily find
speaking courses that
strive to  help you improve only in
this area however knowing a language is
not about mastering one skill
but many in particular there are four
main language skills which
include reading writing listening and
speaking over the years many
students have come to me after
years  of concentrating on just one of the
language skills mentioned
above they want me to help them
fix their language skills
that have now become irregular and
unbalanced the truth is that I have
seen many examples of that for
example someone who can listen and understand
English well but who  can't
even talk  would like a few words someone
who can read well but can't follow
a conversation stories like this
exist in all combinations
after a little research it
always turns out that your skills are
unbalanced
in the decisions you made
throughout your learning journey for example
a  Spanish student told me that he
could read well and listen to the radio but
could barely speak English and was
very frustrated because he
desperately wanted to emigrate to England
naturally I asked him how he
regularly practiced his speaking skills
and well it turns out he had never actually
spoken any English at all
somewhere deep down I just hoped that after
enough listening and reading his
ability to speak would come naturally it did
n't.
naturally to develop the four
ability  en you need to practice all
four skills this does not
necessarily mean dividing your
learning time into four and spending
part of the time reading speaking etc.
but it does mean that you have to
work on developing all those
skills over the course of a
week
or even a  year over time you will
discover that practicing all four
skills together will help reinforce
each other by strengthening
your brain's ability to use and absorb
language in incredible ways
whichever
language learning method you
ultimately choose should not be something you
decide  someone for you, on the other hand, should
come directly from your tastes, desires
and goals as a student the advice of
other people can be useful but
always keep in mind that no one is going to
learn a language for you your
language skills are your
responsibility because the way you
are  structuring your method and how it
grows and evolves over time ta  It
should also be your responsibility and yours alone
as Steve Jobs said in his famous
Stanford commencement speech.
about language learning
including mine listen carefully but take
everything with a grain of salt when you like something
you hear write it down try it out compare it
to other tips and see what results
use your common sense and experience
and ultimately integrate the things
that resonate with you you can  discard the
rest there you have it those are the seven
characteristics of the
language learning method that will work
best for you neither me nor your teachers nor
your friends
if you liked this video you will love
another video I made for
Spanish speakers who want to learn
English and  other languages ​​is like starting
a language from scratch you can see it here
as always thanks for watching and see us
Here's the next video
[Music]